if you want to know what Elon Musk Bill
Gates Warren Buffett and other
successful entrepreneurs and investors
think about Bitcoin then this video is
for you if you're a true adventurer and
you really want to throw the Hail Mary
you might take 10% and put it in Bitcoin
or aetherium but if you do that you've
got to pretend you've already lost your
money i think bitcoin is probably a good
thing it's out of currency I mean it it
does not need to test it for currency it
I wouldn't be surprised if it's not
around in 10 or 20 years what's up
believe they should it's Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in you and
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out into the world instead of help you
on your journey today we're gonna learn
what successful entrepreneurs and
investors think about Bitcoin enjoy
Kameron I want you to explain Bitcoin
for us I mean there are some people out
there who they don't understand what
bitcoin is yeah I went to the florist
the other day and the woman said to me
my son is loving bitcoin he's making all
this money I don't know what it is but
but so tell us why you you know why you
initially got into this business and
what bitcoin is so we think bitcoin is
gold 2.0 it's a store of value and so
today it's about a three hundred billion
dollar market cap gold is that six
trillion so we think it could very well
go up another twenty times from today
we've been saying this since when
Bitcoin was a billion dollar market cap
we've been in Bitcoin for about five
years it's grown about three hundred
times to this point so we think it's
definitely realistic that it could grow
and disrupt gold and maybe even beyond
that so you think that it could actually
replace gold as a safe haven or as a
hedge as a store of value and a hedge
all those things that gold provides in a
portfolio if you look at the
characteristics and properties of gold
like scarce ability portability
divisibility fungibility Bitcoin equals
or surpasses gold so Bitcoin is gold is
scarce Bitcoin is actually fixed at 21
million bitcoins divisible will do 100
million pieces it's way more portable
it's a 24/7 market
I can send Bitcoin to you and your phone
right now or anywhere around the world
very easy to move what happens when I
want to get at when I want to cash in my
bitcoins and I want dollars that's easy
you go to Gemini comm we are in New York
Trust Company we've been building Gemini
for four years so that you can go and
sign up and buy and sell and sort your
Bitcoin in a safe regulated manner we
are the same licensing structure that
companies like State Street and Bank of
New York started out as trust companies
over 200 years ago so we've taken sort
of the old one of the oldest licensing
regulatory frameworks and married it
with one of the newest technologies in
the world it's not easy to do but that's
what we've been working on doing and we
think that's why SIBO was excited to
work with us and price these Bitcoin
futures with the gemini price when i
look at the dollar the dollar
backed by The Full Faith and Trust of
the US government the Treasury what is
Bitcoin backed by just Gemini so
bitcoins no no Gemini's a company on top
of Bitcoin Bitcoin is backed by
cryptography mathematics and one of the
largest computer networks in the world
the dollar being backed by the US
government a lot of people would
cynically say that's injecting
counterparty risk if the government's
collapse currencies are average lifespan
is 27 years something bitcoins more like
a gold goal has been around for
thousands of years so as long as this
math you know persists and the security
of cryptography that's never been hacked
a Bitcoin and as long as the the network
and people continue to believe in it the
same way they believe in United States
as a country or gold as a commodity
bitcoin will have value it's also open
source and it can evolve and grow over
time so the Bitcoin when we first got
into Bitcoin is a very different source
code than today obviously the
fundamentals and the rules are very
similar there's always been 21 million
it's fixed Gold's not fixed it's scarce
we find gold all the time and people
people joke about how you know asteroids
have gold and eventually maybe someone
will let you know they'll on lost or
Jeff Bezos will find gold up there
Bitcoin is actually fixed so I don't
think you have to totally understand all
Bitcoin to to use it to buy it and
invest in it in an asset class similar
to most people don't understand how
email works but they use it and they get
the benefits of email so you know we've
been learning for the past five years
and we'll continue to learn about
Bitcoin but I think the easiest way to
think about Bitcoin is really to
analogize it to gold that's a very good
framework of thinking about it
do you think Bitcoin will be disruptive
in that way and we now it's a
speculative currency will it be
something that will be what normal
consumers would use and will disrupt the
banking industry my opinion but coin is
that I mean I think what coin is
probably a good thing but it's it's
essentially its main I think the thing
we'll be able to probably get quoted in
there but the it it's it's like it's
primarily gonna be a means of doing
illegal transactions but that's not
necessarily entirely bad because what we
in our side you know some things should
be maybe shouldn't be illegal so but the
combination of Silk Road and Bitcoin
will save us well it will be useful for
legal and illegal transactions otherwise
would have no value as a use of for for
legal transaction because you have to
have a legal to illegal bridge yeah I
don't own any Bitcoin the need to move
money from place to place the cost of
doing so the overhead as you put it
makes me think believe it or not of
Bitcoin because some people have said
hey bitcoin is the answer to those
problems are you a believer
well Bitcoin is exciting because it
shows how cheap it can be Bitcoin is is
better than currency and they you don't
have to be physically in the same place
and of course they're large transactions
currency can get pretty inconvenient the
customers we're talking about aren't
trying to be anonymous you know they're
willing to be known so the Bitcoin
technology is key and you could add to
it or you could build a similar
technology where there's enough
attribution that people feel comfortable
this is nothing to do with terrorism or
any type of money laundering
if you're a true adventurer and you
really want to throw the Hail Mary
you might take 10% and put it in Bitcoin
or aetherium but if you do that you've
gotta pretend you've already lost your
money and it's like collecting art it's
like collecting baseball cards it's like
collecting shoes you know something's
worth what somebody else will pay for it
it's a fire but I'd limit it to 10%
if you ask what are the things where
there's you know what's very charismatic
and that people are not paying enough
attention to I think there are these
pockets in biotech that I find like that
you know the one other ones I've been
looking at a lot more have been the
crypto currencies and and what I'm
skeptical of most of them I do think
people are are are a little bit maybe
maybe under estimating Bitcoin
specifically because it is like it's
like a reserved form of money it's like
gold and and it's just a store of value
you don't actually need you to use to
make payments and it's been you know
it's there's about 70 billion dollars
worth of Bitcoin in the world there's
nine trillion worth of gold and and if
Bitcoin ends up being the cyber
equivalent of gold and it has a it has a
it has a great potential love so that's
and it's a it's a very different kind of
thing from what people so people in
Silicon Valley normally focus on
companies not you know algorithms or
protocols but this may be this may be
one exception that's uh that's very
underestimated
well people question it and I know
there's been so much debate about
Bitcoin but they question it because
what is it based on I mean you see that
the dollar is based on you know the the
trust of the Treasury the trust of US
government what is Bitcoin based on well
the the argument it's based on the on
the security of the map which tells you
that it can never be it can never be
deluded by a government it can never it
can never be it can't be hacked and it's
a form of money that's absolutely that's
secure in an absolute way and of course
you could ask the same questions about
gold that's why I use the gold analogy
you say what is gold based on why it's
gold valuable well it's it's a tangible
asset it's a tangible asset but it's
also hard to mine so if it was easy to
mine gold then it wouldn't be that
dialects we just have way more gold
so Bitcoin is also it's it's my noble
like gold it's hard to mine it's
actually harder to mine and go
old and so in that sense it's it's more
constrained and so yeah they're there
number of things that that that I think
make it somewhat similar to gold and
then the question is just does this
become does this become more widely and
it's anonymous right I mean that's one
of the beauties of it you can be
anonymous using Bitcoin yes it's a half
anonymous half not so it's it's again
this intermediate thing there's a
question whether that's right or not but
it's it's a bearer instrument so if you
if you have the Bitcoin if you know the
key you can you can go anywhere most the
time most securities are registered not
bearer securities so it's a very unusual
kind of a security honestly I'm not that
big fan of bitcoins but I'm a I pay
special attention to the - to the
cashless society blockchain technology
Bitcoin the the thing I want to know is
that what Valley what things that the
Bitcoin can bring to the society but the
higher the Bitcoin the technology the
self really very powerful so my job in
Alibaba re pays job is trying to making
sure that we will move the world will
move into a cashless society the society
can make everybody equal make everybody
inclusive to get them get the money they
need and making sure it's a sustainable
inclusive and transparent
I hate corruption I don't have
opportunity it's okay but I don't want
somebody through dirty way take away my
opportunity this is why we want a
cashless society but Bitcoin we
watch it very carefully I would not say
I'm a fan of bitcoins
I'm always also as curious as you are
and I don't think unex from that I don't
pretend I know there's one thing that I
want to share with all of you
one day when you do business I'll do
whatever if you don't know it's not
shameful but if you don't know but you
pretend you know it is very shameful I
don't know about bitcoins
it's not a currency I mean it it does
not meet the test of a currency it I
wouldn't be surprised if it's not around
in 10 or 20 years why does it not meet
the definition of the currency well
because then people say well I'll show
you goods and bitcoins but they change
the price of those every time the price
of the dollar changes in relations but
their pricing off the dollar they could
say well I'll sell it to you in barrels
of oil but if they check every time the
price of oil changes they change the
number of barrels you have to have
that's not your oil is not the currency
let me ask you about Bitcoin okay
Bitcoin people say the same thing it's a
store of value you've got to have
diversified the dollars not safe there
are two purposes of a currency is it a
medium of exchange and is it a store
hold of wealth those are the basic
ingredients bitcoin is not an effective
medium exchange by and large and if I
coach I have a Bitcoin I don't want to
go buy things it's not easy to buy
things with the Bitcoin and in terms of
a store hold of wealth a store hold of
wealth more reflects like gold more
reflects the opposite of what money is
doing right and so you look at it's a
store hold of wealth bitcoin is a
speculative it's a speculative bubble
right its price is like a greater fool
theory in terms of its price if you say
what is its intrinsic value if if
bitcoin was made into a more effective
medium of exchange and also operated in
terms of a store hold of wealth not of
the reflection of that volatility it
would be a viable instrument it is to me
a vehicle for speculation that's
attracting people in and it has all the
classic ingredients of a bubble people
leveraging themselves up and it doesn't
have that same intrinsic value even the
privacy value okay is suspect suspicious
in other words it has a purpose to some
extent if you're living in a country and
you don't know your currency it was
whether it's gonna be good or not and
you might hole try to hold that but that
thing you're holding is running around
like crazy for reasons that you don't
understand and then it's so it's not
going to be an effective store holder
wealth and the privacy will be stress
tested in other words governments are
examining who is operating in their own
clever ways of what that and so you
can't even assume that that's so it's
gonna be a privacy vehicle so I don't
see the effectiveness of Bitcoin I could
see cyber secure currencies and and so
on but crypto currencies but this is not
what we're having it's it's you know
it's a possibility that I think is has
been captured as a speculative vehicle
that
in the middle of a bubble
bitcoin is something that you've been
interested in and supportive of in fact
one can pay for a tour on Virgin
Galactic up to the moon with Bitcoin I
think the the Winklevoss twins have said
that they would do exactly that this is
a currency a currency that's really
gonna work eventually I think it is
working and there will be other
currencies like it that may maybe even
better but in the meantime there's a big
industry around Bitcoin and you know
people have made fortunes that Bitcoin
some people have lost my net a Bitcoin
phenomenal it's volatile yeah it is
quite volatile but and but you know when
involves it volatility people can make
money how to volatility why was it
important for you to give it sort of
that stamp of approval that endorsement
by saying to the Winklevoss twins yes
you can pay for the the ride with
Bitcoin because I'm not foolish Evan if
people have got lots of bitcoins then
they want to go to space I much rather
they spent that money on our spaceship
of whether I keep little bitcoins is
another rather they spend that money on
a Virgin Galactic spaceship then on you
know even we'll be sending people to
space one day on Elon spaceships they
will grab the money well it's well it's
there thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love to
know what did you think of this video
there's a mix of different opinions on
Bitcoin on where it's going I'd love to
know who do you think is right whose
advice you're going to listen to is
there your own tape that you want to add
to it as well to help your fellow
members a belief nation leave it down in
the comments below I'm really excited to
hear from you so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is much love
see you soon raise your standard Apple
at the core is core value
is that maybe that people have passion
and change the way people now one drop
of myself work depends on your it's
suppose to me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten Rose a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details